hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2020 thriller movie called promising
young woman this movie is about a young
woman haunted by a traumatic past as she
navigates balancing forgiveness and
vengeance
the movie begins with a woman alone at a
bar appearing incredibly intoxicated
barely able to keep her head up and
falling over in her seat she is then
noticed by three average guys and one of
them named jerry who claims himself to
be a good guy decides to approach her
and offer to pick her home
while on their way home jerry suggests
that they can go to his apartment first
it turns out that jerry is not a very
good guy
despite her being barely conscious he
still offers her alcoholic drink and
starts to kiss her he even moves her to
his bed and begins to do inappropriate
things only to realize that the woman is
not drunk and has been faking it for the
whole time leaving jerry in shock
the woman is cassie a medical student
dropout on the brink of 30 who has no
professional ambitions has no boyfriend
and still lives with her parents house
she currently works at a coffee shop to
fill his daily boring days
cassie whose best friend nina was raped
when the two were in medical school
though nina reported the rape and though
there was video evidence no one at the
school took her claim seriously and
punished the perpetrators that is the
reason both nina and cassie left school
and it's heavily implied that nina later
died by suicide
one day at the coffee shop cassie meets
ryan who appears to be her former
classmate at the medical university he
is confused with the fact that she works
as a barista but soon he asks cassie to
go on a date with him but rejected
as shown previously cassie now spends
her nights in nearby bars faking herself
as a drunk woman and posing as bait for
men to take her to their homes then
revealing sobriety when they try to take
advantage of her embarrassing them and
keeping a record of how many men that
has fallen into her trap
on cassie's 30th birthday her parents
give her a present and her mother starts
to scold him saying that it is very
strange for a mature woman to still live
in her parents house without having a
boyfriend and a friend
surprisingly the gift turns out to be a
suitcase showing that her parents want
her to get out immediately
ryan comes back to the coffee shop to
try his second attempt claiming that
cassie gave him a fake number the other
day
funny thing is that ryan spent several
hours composing a very romantic text
only to find out that the message was
sent to an oil rig worker called red
this time he confesses that he has liked
cassie since high school and asks her to
go for lunch
finally cassie goes on a legitimate date
with ryan both of them start to develop
a closer relationship and ryan seems to
be a real good person he asks cassie to
visit his apartment and she agrees with
that but suddenly he feels that it is
too fast and he offers to drive her home
eventually it makes cassie upset and she
goes home alone as ryan is already at
his apartment
the next day cassie visits ryan at the
hospital as he is currently working as a
pediatrician and says that she wants to
continue the relationship but he has to
take it slow at night ryan mentions one
of his friends al-monroe the man who
sent cassie on this spiral of grief and
trauma has just moved back from london
and is getting married which makes
cassie upset
since then she begins to plan a strategy
to revenge nina on al and others who are
responsible for him getting away with
the rape she then meets another former
classmate madison they have little
conversation and we can see that cassie
purposely wants to get madison drunk by
keeping pouring her champagne
cassie brings up the topic nina's raped
several years ago but madison keeps
denying that nina was raped and
implicitly says that it was nina's drunk
for getting drunk which disappoints
cassie turns out that cassie also hires
a man to take the drunk madison to a
hotel room
with no memory of what has happened
because she was drunk madison leaves
several distraught voicemails to cassie
who doesn't answer her call
the next target is the university's dean
elizabeth walker but before that cassie
lures walker's teenage daughter amber
into her car by posing as a new makeup
artist for the popular band called wet
dreams
cassie tells the teenager that she is
lost and her phone is dead because it is
amber's favorite band amber is willing
to help by borrowing her phone to cassie
after her plan works she later meets
walker under the pretense of resuming
her med school education and asks her
about nina's case and almond row
here cassie reveals that al took nina
and raped her repeatedly in front of his
friends while she was drunk the dean
seemed not to take the case seriously at
the time and even didn't remember the
case
walker even implicitly says that nina
shouldn't have been drunk at that time
despite her being the victim to punish
the dean cassie tells her that she
dropped her daughter at a dorm room with
male students
at first walker doesn't believe her and
threatens cassie but when cassie hands
over her daughter's phone she becomes
terrified and eventually apologizes for
her action
at the end cassie reveals that she is
lying and her daughter is safe at the
diner
even after building a good relationship
with ryan cassie keeps acting as a drunk
woman in the bar looking for a poor boy
to become her victim but unfortunately
she meets ryan there while hooking up
with a guy
ryan is disappointed and leaves her
alone
the next day cassie continues his
revenge plan by meeting jordan green
al's lawyer on nina's case who forces
nina to drop the charges green then
apologizes to cassie and claims that he
will never forgive himself for what he
has done
because of that cassie forgives green
and walks away canceling her plan to
harm the lawyer with a hitman
after that cassie visits nina's mother
flashbacking their good memories with
nina nida's mom urges cassie to forget
it and move on because it brings no good
to everyone especially nina
after that cassie spots a post
containing information about al-munro's
bachelor party but she decides to
abandon her revenge plans
she also visits ryan and apologizes to
him begging to start their relationship
from the beginning
at first ryan still cannot accept the
reality but later he approaches cassie
at the coffee shop and they finally kiss
for the first time and fall in love with
each other cassie even invites ryan to
her house and introduces him to her
parents
cassie is confronted by madison outside
her house
she urges cassie to tell her what
happened while she was drunk after their
lunch cassie assures her that the man
only put her on the bed and nothing bad
happened
on that occasion madison hands over an
old phone containing a video of nina's
getting raped and warns cassie to never
contact her again
while looking at the footage cassie
discovers that ryan was there as a
bystander and decides to move forward on
the revenge plan
the next day cassie visits ryan at the
hospital and shows the recording to him
she threatens ryan that she will send it
to his colleagues except he tells cassie
where al-monroe's bachelor party will be
held
not willing to risk her career as a
pediatrician he finally gives the
address to cassie ryan also demands
forgiveness but cassie refuses to do so
their relationship ends there
cassie arrives at al's bachelor party
disguising herself as a nurse stripper
al's friend seems to be very happy about
cassie's arrival not knowing what will
happen next cassie starts her show
she orders all the boys to kneel down
and start feeding them with a huge
amount of drink
she takes al upstairs and handcuffs him
to the bed
when asked about her name she answers
that she is nina fisher which surprised
al because the real nina is dead and
suddenly begs her to let him go
he screams for help but cassie has
drugged his friends with a drink before
al insists that he didn't do anything at
that time and says that nina was also
into it cassie starts carving nina's
name onto al skip but al suddenly
manages to break free
he tries to stop her but cassie keeps
fighting back because of that he grabs a
pillow and smothers cassie with it for a
very long time causing her to die
because of suffocating in the morning a
friend joe approaches him in the room
and is shocked after knowing the fact
that al has killed the stripper both of
them then managed to get rid of cassie's
body to cover up their crime
after disappearing for several days
cassie's parents file a missing person
report to the police and detective
waller begins to investigate the case by
interviewing ryan
he actually knows where cassie went but
he refuses to tell the detective
later at al's wedding the final act of
cassie's plan unfolds as ryan receives
several pre-scheduled texts from cassie
telling him that things aren't finished
cassie's manager also receives a
half-heart-shaped necklace with cassie's
name written on it also the cops
suddenly show up there managed to find
the matching half with nina's name in
cassie's burnt remains and arrest al for
the crime he has committed lastly it
turns out that cassie had sent the
location of the bachelor party and the
proof of the rape to the remorseful
lawyer telling him to contact the police
if she disappeared
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching